victoria garantizada eso es lo que
cantan en el escenario el candidato pro
beijing carl ichán y sus partidarios
mientras se preparan para celebrar una
rotunda victoria electoral chan y otros
candidatos pro beijing dominaron las
elecciones legislativas de hong kong
superando a los moderados e
independientes
creo que es una noticia falsa llamarla
elecciones falsas porque son elecciones
reales y nos han elegido los votantes
creo que debemos respetar las elecciones
de los electores esto es la democracia a
pesar de estas afirmaciones solo voto el
30 por ciento del padrón electoral
registrado la participación más baja
desde la entrega de la ciudad china de
no votamos porque no va a suponer
ninguna diferencia es una elección de
círculo pequeño las elecciones fueron
las primeras que se celebraron desde que
beijing reformó el sistema electoral de
hong kong a principios de este año las
reformas permitieron a beijing
investigar a todos los candidatos y
limitar drásticamente el número de
escaños elegidos directamente en el
consejo legislativo cuatro millones y
medio de residentes tenían derecho a
votar pero sus papeletas sólo decidieron
escaños de 90 el resto fueron elegidos
directamente por comités pro beijing y
sectores profesionales y empresariales
como el financiero y el de construcción